hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with an attack on the
compliance tip of the week yeah this
week we're talking about cmmc control
au.l2-3.3.8 protect audit information
and audit logging tools from
unauthorized access modification and
deletion whatever that means
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone try to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 10171 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got green news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's get into
it
so in cmmc control
au.l2-3.3.8 protect audit information
and audit logging tools from
unauthorized access modification and
deletion so here we have our friends at
Nara and nist doing a little thinking
ahead for us one of the most important
things about evidence Gathering is
making sure the evidence doesn't
disappear on you to that tune this
control mandates that seem log
information and the seam system itself
cannot be tampered with at on-call We
Love Solutions where steam log data
becomes immutable so they cannot be
changed once it's written if you're not
sure what kind of seam system to choose
or what a seam system is it might be a
good time to give us a call and our
certified compliance and cyber Security
Experts can definitely help you out but
in the meanwhile again the point here is
make sure that it's tamper-proof that
there's maybe a separate login system to
it or that some way it's guarded so that
only authorizers can get at it let's
check out what the assessors are really
looking for on this one to make them
happy now on this one you've got one two
three four five six a whole lot of stuff
that's going to get assessed so Point
number one is determining if audit
information is protected from
unauthorized access so number one is it
protected uh and if I was to give a
sample answer on this I would really
just describe sort of the login system
to the seam so again we would say maybe
something like it's Implement via the
same solution only seam administrators
have access to the system in other words
it's a whole separate isolated air gap
type of system and only they can get in
the next thing I talk about is
determining if audit information is
protected from unauthorized modification
so seam log files are held in immutable
storage right so again just kind of
pulling from our example of earlier we
really love the idea that steam storage
is immutable you really can't alter it
once it's written until it reaches a
certain age or you know whatever the
criteria is for overriding it uh so
again that's the example we would give
there determine if audit information is
protected from unauthorized deletion
again it's solved easily because if it's
immutable storage you can't get to it
there's other great cloud-based systems
that we've seen and I won't name any
names until we've received some
sponsorship dollars of course but there
are some great Cloud Solutions out there
that just simply don't give the
administrator access to where those seam
log files are are charged excuse me uh
stored and so as a result essentially
they just kind of don't have access to
those files to even create an
unauthorized deletion scenario
now assessment Point number four
determine if audit logging tools are
protected from unauthorized access this
is implemented via the same solution
user access system okay so again if you
have an isolated air gap seam system
maybe that's not part of active
directory as something completely
separate you could uh in this example
again have separate users that have
access just to the system pretty cool
way of doing it and again very very
common uh assessment Point number five
determine if audit logging tools are
protected from unauthorized modification
again seam system seam solution tools
are not modifiable from the vendor
typically this is going to be the case
now if you made your own seam system and
we've come across clients who've done
that you're then going to have to figure
out a way to protect that system from
unauthorized user access and Define that
so be ready if you built your own or
you're sort of piecemeal with a couple
different solutions you're going to have
to really be ready for the assessor to
dive in on you there and make sure that
there's nothing uh you know nothing no
holes in terms of how people could get
to the data itself now final assessment
point is determining if audit logging
tools are protected from unauthorized
deletion in other words Kate can I just
delete you know the c major or something
like that could I just delete whatever
it is that's pulling the log files uh
so you know again we sort of use the
example of hey look the same solution
cannot be deleted uh because well it's
it belongs to a third-party provider you
simply can't delete it and anytime that
the same agent might not be functioning
correctly it would it would send an
alert or there would be an alert from
the same system coming to us to let us
know Hey listen this agent's not uh you
know it's not functioning properly go
fix it so again lots of ways to sort of
answer that one but again most steam
systems will have all this built in you
just have to really have a good
understanding and ability to explain it
here to an auditor so they know that you
know how it works and if you don't know
how it should work well then I got a
solution for you you can call us here at
on call because we work with defense
contractors just like you who've had
this defars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped in their laps
like a seagull on a sunny day we teach
you how to level up and be a proper
on-call compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps gray areas and getting
this all solved while showing you how to
leverage compliance is your secret
weapon to land more Defense work higher
profit margins now that is what becoming
an on-call compliance hero can do for
you and if you're looking for more help
getting compliant our compliance experts
are always on call for you visit CMC
compliance secrets.com or check out the
bio below for links to get help right
now if you love the content we're
putting out there for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button right now to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance service roll it out until the
next compliance tip my friends stay safe
and secure out there hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance I'll
see you on the next one
[Music]
all right